robin and joan rivers were on a plane
together they were
and i guess the whole plane could hear
their conversation oh get out of here
you entered it up on the whole
flight not the whole flight we went uh
uh she read a book for a while and fell
asleep and i fell asleep
so exhausting when you sit next to
somebody you know and they just want to
talk the whole [ __ ] time
yeah and then it's annoying when you
want to talk and then the person's
asleep like with
faff i know we can never get the right
mix
i told you that story
i was on the arsenio hall show and it
went horribly wrong
and i was thrown out you know physically
thrown out of the building and
was with me and i was so traumatized i
had a
first class ticket to go back to new
york and fufufue was in coach and i said
i'm upgrading you
i said i asked you to by the way this is
the point you leave out of the store i
said
it's not necessary i'm going to sleep
and you're like no no i want to do this
for you
of course 10 o'clock a times one o'clock
in the morning new york time let's start
there
what we got in the red eye it's ten
o'clock
l a time which means it's one o'clock in
the morning new york no it wasn't
it was ten o'clock for us we'd been in
l.a for a while yeah you were on l.a
the second he sits down and i'm like
jesus christ thank god i got gary or at
least you got someone to talk to because
this was really bad
it was eerie for you you had just yeah
the moment you got off the air
you called me and said how bad was that
because i was watching it they used to
do it live
and i could watch it in new york live
yeah
you were just shaking yeah i mean it was
great like it was like wild it was
sort of legendary but jesus christ when
you're the guy doing it your [ __ ]
whole body shakes you know you're like
jesus christ i just went out there and
act like a madman then
baba booey i put him back on the plane
with me and i upgrade him to first class
because i really need someone to talk to
and the [ __ ] puts himself to
sleep like a baby
he just he just goes bull i'm really
tired and
i'm like how could he sleep we just went
through something very traumatic
we didn't you did yeah but you were
there
it was just weird and then like halfway
through the flight he wakes up and goes
he licks his choppers because they're
all dry favorite part of the story
[Music]
is dry and he goes both
i gotta get some orange juice it's like
okay good he's up i'll talk to him now
because i'm staring at him the whole
time and his [ __ ] mouth is open and
he goes
look at some juice and then he gets the
juice and he licks his lips and
teeth and then he goes
and he goes he puts himself right back
to bed with his
juice you know what's [ __ ] up about
that in the history
and then we went i had to wake him up
when we hit new york in the history of
me flying
i've never ever slept like that i swear
to god
here's what i remember the plane took
off i believe at 10 30
and i remember being asleep before it
took off which is rare for me
i was gonna kill myself and i remember
having a waste of money i was looking
forward to going to sleep but howard
goes
i'm going to upgrade you and i go you
know what i'm just going to sleep here
and i'm fine where i am he's like no i
want to do this for you
that was weird i didn't want the guy
back and coach when i'm in first class
this would have been weird
but i i even remember howard like going
hey we're landing
i i'm staring at him the whole time just
going oh my god i just cannot believe
that he
is not talking and then when the juice
happened i was like thrilled because
i give it a drink now i remember that
never forget that sounds like
that's what i love when you do that
he was dry and then he does you know he
licks he goes like this
see the thing that sucks about the story
for me howard is whenever you tell the
story everything
[Laughter]
[Music]
juice
[Music]
i want you to see this is the part that
humiliates me where robin has to take
her glasses off
to get a tissue on her eyes because the
tears are coming up you see this
look at that let remember i told you
about this yeah
this is [ __ ] humiliating she's
laughing but look at this she's having a
good time
she likes when i lick my blood
unbelievable she likes when you do the
teeth
looking good why don't you guys go get a
[ __ ] dinner reservation
and go do this dude at a table this gets
you when i do that right oh it kills me